thank you very much everybody it's great
to be here so I'd like to start by
telling you about Thomas so Thomas ever
since he could walk has been has been
told and has had continuously here that
he's smart not only from his parents but
also from any adult that's come in
contact with this very precocious child
when he tested out for kindergarten his
smartness was statistically confirmed he
tested at the Anderson School which is
up here on 70 west 77th street in new
york city PS 334 I think it is it's a
school for advanced kids anyway he
tested statistically not only at the top
one percent of kids his age but at the
top 1% of the top 1% so you can't get
much smarter than that I think
so he has a picture of Thomas isn't he
cute fast forward this is when he was
this was taken when he was five years
old in the fifth grade actually so he he
cut his hair to look like somebody that
he modeled after on TV he loves to wear
cargo pants but he especially loves
hanging out with the smart kids and
that's five kids who are all at the
Anderson school and they're smart and he
loves doing that because he feels he
belongs he fits in that's where he
belongs you know so unfortunately
Thomas's self awareness of being smart
has not only as not always translated
into his ability to succeed in school in
fact it's been quite the contrary he
might be surprised to know that both his
parents and teachers were very very
frustrated with him he didn't want to
learn spelling he didn't want to learn
cursive writing fractions was like a
major speed bump in the course of
progress in his academic life and I mean
not just a little bit of resistance here
not just a little bit of difficulty it
was pain his parents and teachers had to
prop rod and pull and cajole and he
ultimately mastered these routine tasks
but it was not easy in fact it was quite
surprising that Thomas being
statistically so on top of everything
everybody else would have such
difficulty and such a lack of confidence
in his own ability that he wouldn't try
something new
how many of you know a child or have a
child like Thomas anybody maybe some of
you have even been a Thomas in your past
at some point or another have you we are
a few yes Aaron so Thomas was studied by
a noted child psychologist Carol Dweck
and she came up with a rationale for why
his behavior didn't really match his
ability at least at the start of his
academic career so we're gonna say
goodbye to Thomas right here and I'm
gonna flick over it we're going to come
back to him in a moment so I'd like to
introduce you to what is tantamount to
the contrapositive of Thomas in other
words these women here on the cover of
my book women in data which I published
which o'reilly media published earlier
this year and which explores why these
women here despite all odds despite the
fact that many other women can't succeed
why they are succeeding have succeeded
and continue to succeed in the tech IT
and STEM fields so I like to concentrate
on something that's positive in other
words not the null set the people who
are complaining and victims of conscious
and unconscious bias prejudices and the
like I want to find out what people are
doing who are successful what can we
learn from these women what can we clone
and and learn for ourselves and apply to
our own lives so for instance we have
Alice Alice's story was that when she
was six she failed math and this was an
incredible embarrassment to her family
her father who was a noted Chinese
diplomat who traveled a lot for work
took off from work absolutely decided
hands on all hands on
to tutor Allison math and as a result of
that tutoring and that continuous
support from her father alice is now a
renowned data science scientist and a
preeminent company who goes around the
world lecturing on machine learning
algorithms and computer network security
she has a ba in math and MA in computer
science and a PhD in electrical
engineering very different from Thomas
Margot on the other hand Margot story is
that she almost dropped out of math
despite the fact that both her parents
our math teachers because she was the
only one in the group and when two other
women joined her half the school math
class she decided to stick it out so now
she not only has a master's in math but
she has her own company and she's doing
very sophisticated trading algorithms
and platforms very very advanced really
super we have neha is another case
that's interesting neha never she was
practically the only woman ever in
anything she ever got started in she was
the only woman on any of her teams that
LinkedIn she was always the top of the
top of the file as far as achievements
go and she later recently actually last
year formed her own company with two
male partners and really never gave it a
second thought that she was a woman in
tech she just just went ahead and did it
she was she's a combination of beauty
and brains so they're always another
that was so interesting to do this work
so he is another story a woman who
really hit the trifecta if you will she
at age 17 was an unmarried mother of two
babies no money and no college degree so
her story is that today
she is a data scientist has her own
company and provides services to the
fortune 500 a remarkable story other
women told me that they were afraid to
go ahead in the tech field because they
wouldn't be considered feminine a lot of
them told me that they had what's called
the impostor syndrome some of them loved
science and math but they were afraid
that they'd never have a boyfriend or
get married if they pursued their
current their passion for the detective
data field so despite all of these
issues anxiety worries they managed to
surmount them and plow ahead through
with courage and faith and become
successful and they continue to be
successful so what are the factors that
were involved in their success so you
might say that all of them were very
smart there's no doubt about it the
brainiacs they had supportive parents a
lot of them had supportive male figures
in their background in other words
brothers fathers co-workers bosses who
all helped them along we're very
understanding and encourage them they
are also very persistent and they had a
passion for their subject but there's
one big big big factor that really sets
them apart as far as comparing them to
Thomas and I'm going to tell you about
that in a minute
so to put the situation in a bit of
context and give you some perspective on
why these women's success and
achievements in this field is so
remarkable and so spectacular and we
should applaud it take a look because
I'm sorry that this is a little blurred
on the top screen but we have all
students I'm talking here about the
academic world students who come into
the STEM fields that's all students on
the top chart a hundred percent of them
coming in nineteen percent graduate with
a stem degree ten percent are working in
stem after three years and eight percent
are working in stem after ten years now
on the bottom we have the situation for
women which is quite a bit worse we have
women entering college here how to
present them twelve percent of women are
graduating with stem degrees five
percent working and call working after
three years and only three percent
working in a stem field after ten years
so think of it as kind of a wave coming
in on the left and which kind of Peters
out to a trickle on the other end both
from men and women so the conclusion
here is that we're simply not attracting
enough people and especially not enough
women into the tech and stem feels in
fact the number that we need so that's
academia in the workplace there's a
similar situation where women are
underrepresented and despite many pretty
much progress of late in the area what
we have what we can notice is that forty
five percent of women starting out our
entrance into a tech field and a tech
company thirty two percent are met our
managers thirty-seven percent of Merit
managers thirty two percent are senior
manager
that goes down to twenty-seven percent
VPS 23% senior VPS and only seventeen
percent are on the upper echelon of the
corporate hierarchy so the picture is
this is a summary the picture is women
are about fifty one percent of the
population fifty-nine percent of the US
workforce but are still a very small
sliver of the tech world now
interestingly enough women have really
made a lot of progress over the last
couple of decades for instance we have
we have we are now graduating more
bachelor's degrees fifty-seven percent
of all US bachelor's degrees today are
women fifty-seven percent of
professional jobs are women 60 a full
sixty percent of master's degrees are
earned by women and even fifty one
percent of PhDs are earned by women so
we really have we really have a huge
question of support we'd really have a
supply of women in the workforce who are
well tour trained albeit not in the STEM
fields so that's the supplies I now on
the demand side there is a tremendous
growth in fact it's the fastest growing
sector of the US economy is the stem and
antec area we the stem occupations are
scheduled to grow from 6.8 million jobs
to 28 million jobs by 2018 which is
right around the corner job openings are
will provide 2.4 million jobs 1.1 net
new and 1.3 replacement jobs and also
these are very good jobs these are
well-paying jobs where there's a lot of
creativity a lot of advancement and a
lot of movement although there's a
little bit of a differential always
between men and women salary in the STEM
fields there's less differential here's
a statistic that I find particularly
interesting eighty percent 800k eighty
percent of future careers future careers
will require stem skel skilled workers
and some foundational knowledge of
computer science so this should be very
very good news to everybody here in this
audience because you're all techies
you're all well trained you can look
forward to a career that is very
satisfying with this opportunity
so more or less they consider 1.2
between 1.1 1.4 million new jobs by 2020
is what we're looking for and it's
arguably the tech field is arguably the
most important growth engine for the
economy where they're looking for the
creativity the ingenuity and the
problem-solving skills that are involved
with tech to really grow the economy but
we're facing serious shortages in stem
competencies over two-thirds of the jobs
that we need and will have will go
unfilled and also a majority this is
kind of surprising a majority of us
middle and high school students don't
even take any stem courses and don't
have any computer science courses in
their schools so we're not preparing
kids for the future the eighty percent
that of jobs which will require some
tech skills in the future and we're not
preparing the country for the economic
success and growth that we could have if
we were more let's say how to shot in
the arm of vitamin tech
this is a slide that I found very
surprising as far as where we are
academically in the United States if you
look at the red arrows this is a this is
the these are the results of the latest
Pisa analysis Pisa is an international
ranking service that ranks countries by
their reading math and science skills so
in 2012 the United States dropped in
from 25th to 30 first place in math from
eleventh place to twenty first place in
reading and from twenty to twenty-four
percent in science and that's just in
the space of three years now
interestingly enough if if we were just
to match the level of the OECD countries
which is the line in blue that you see
the solid line in blue there the OECD
represents 30 fork the average of 34
countries in your it's basically the
European Union if we were to match that
level we would actually add according to
their calculation one-point-seven
percent to the US gross domestic product
which is amazing merely increasing the
retention of stem concentration in
colleges would also give us a very very
big boost to our economy if we were to
merely increase the retention of our
stem majors from 40 to ten fifty fifty
percent 10 percentage points we would
generate three-quarters of the targeted
million stem degrees over the next
decade so a retention strategy in the
college level would be a low-cost and
great way to boost the economy
and women represent a vastly untapped
talent pool to fill this need so we have
to sum up we have a supply situation
where the woman women are out there
untapped for important stem jobs
technical jobs and we have a demand that
is very very high for stem jobs so we
have an unequal situation between supply
and demand how do we match the supply
and the demand how do we match the
resources we have with the opportunity
that's out there and how do we encourage
women to get into these fields and stay
now don't laugh right so actually
actually it won't take in a hundred
years actually there are some solutions
that are out there and that are
beginning to pay off so and I'm going to
propose a solution actually so let's
revisit the situation with Thomas for a
moment Thomas was studied by the noted
child psychologist Carol Dweck who
determined that what he was doing as far
as what he was told he was so smart was
he was focusing on burnishing his image
of being smart it was kind of like a
defensive strategy that he had adopted
to protect his appearance and his image
of being smart rather than on the on the
other hand really rolling up his sleeves
and getting into the habit of learning
and working hard to tackle the next
challenges that came up in his academic
career so
what Thomas didn't have but which the my
O'Reilly cover girls had all of them
without exception something called a
growth mindset I've been has anyone ever
heard of a growth mindset fabulous so if
you have a fixed mindset as opposed to a
growth mindset fixed mindset people they
believe that intelligence is something
that's static you or any talent you're
either born with it or you're not and
that's it it's kind of a zero-sum game
this attitude of a fixed mindset leads
to a desire to look smart and therefore
a tendency to avoid taking any risk to
give up easily when there's any
challenge to ignore any useful feedback
and to be threatened by the success of
others on the other hand if you have a
growth mindset and you believe that
intelligence can be developed that
intelligence leads to it that that leads
to a desire to learn and therefore a
tendency to embrace challenges to
persist and hang in there despite any
difficulties to see effort as a path to
mastery to learn from criticism and to
be inspired by others success in fact if
you have a growth mindset there's
virtually no such thing as failure
because every failure is amortized into
your experience so that you learn
constantly on a continuous learning
curve and you progress the next time at
if you have a fixed mindset which was
Thomas's issue these people tend to
plateau very quickly and they really
don't ever reach the full potential that
they're capable of if others are
succeeding they believe they can't so
they really have a tremendous
kind of inferiority complex that comes
from this fixed mindset situation
the reason why the basis for having a
fixed of having a growth mindset is
based on the neural plasticity of the
brain and it's the old saw you know the
more you use the brain the more develops
the more you can do so for example
people who have a fixed mindset they
might say I'm not good at math but if
you have a growth mindset you say I'm
not good at math not yet if you are a
fixed mindset you say I give up a growth
mindset person will say I'll use a
different strategy fixed person might
say I'm not good at this growth mindset
what am I missing fixed mindset I can't
make this better growth I can always
improve fixed mindset plan a didn't work
growth mindset there's always a plan B
I'm not a math person not yet I'm not
succeeding in fill in the blank not yet
so wonder if fix minds that if you fail
or you make a mistake there's it's a
catastrophe you're you fall from your
perch of looking smart it's an attack
against your self image and the image
that other people have a view is being
smart you have a growth mindset and no
big deal there's no such thing as
failure because everything is a constant
learning cycle
so I'm encouraging everybody to continue
adopting a philosophy of growth mindset
and not yet it's when you believe in not
yet as I've just described you see
yourself on a continuum a continuous
process of going forward it's a path to
victory it's a path to the future and
the path to success progress is possible
you are not fixed like Thomas thought he
was you're on a learning curve now think
of what would happen if we could change
our mindsets and if we changed our
mindsets changing mindsets changes the
world and I'm asking that we consider
speaking to children and educating
children with a growth mindset and the
concept of not yet being introduced to
our educational challenges now in our
corporate culture and our corporate
workplaces where most of us hangout
mindset is also a big factor in progress
learning and success
so I have a very large database of
articles studies research analyses and
the like that demonstrate that when
women are included in in companies that
is on the corporate boards on the
leadership teams or on the work teams
there's a there's a definite provable
improvement in productivity performance
and profitability so I don't have time
to tell you all of this about this but
you will have to take it on faith I'm a
I'm a scientist I'm a researcher and so
I respect the science and I know that
what I'm hearing and reading about is
authentic and true so here is a woman
meet Karen Rubin so I heard Karen speak
in September at strada and hadoop world
here at the Javits Center and she did an
amazingly robust study so it was a
comparison that showed 80 80 women who
were CEOs in companies compared to non
women CEOs from companies didn't have
women CEOs during a fixed over a fixed
time pair 12 year period between 2002
and 2014 so get this the comparison
showed that 80 women CEOs during that
12-year period produced equity returns
two hundred and twenty six percent
better than the S&P 500
now here's a slide just parenthetically
Mackenzie feels that if women were
included globally into teams and
companies they'd be at 12 trillion
dollar global growth okay so that's a
big number so um are there any Stanford
grads in the audience besides myself
okay so Doug wild at Stanford he's a
professor emeritus of mechanical
engineering and he did a remarkable
study over a longitudinal study right
it's 25 quarter of a century 25 years
and he is that was the one responsible
for designing all of those robotic cars
and time and time again he experimented
over and over again with what kind of
teams should you organize that would
correlate to successful teams winning
robot winning rope the robotics prizes
and a hands down time and time again
what the result was is that the diverse
personalities of collaborative teams and
the combined skills of people on these
diverse teams showed that there with
their personnel with their different
personalities they would they made the
difference they made all the difference
and they won they bore the successful
robotics teams so under Doug wild
stanford won three times more prizes
than anybody out than any other
competing team in these robotics
competitions so here this is a very very
robust body of evidence another one
that's pretty interesting is Tom Malone
another very big sample size very very
robust analyses showing why women
teams make the team smarter so according
to him what makes a great team is not
the IQ of the individual team members
that results in higher performance it's
the collective ability of the group in
fact it's the group's eq the emotional
e.q and he found I could have put this
on audio but I didn't know a high
correlation between the number of women
on the teams on a team the corporate
world and the productivity and
performance of the team so let's think
about this for a minute we're all part
of work teams and various other kinds of
teams where we have to get a job done so
you might think that the way to get a
team together is you just go out there
you hire a bunch of smart people and
you'll throw them together and that's it
it turns out that that's not it it turns
out that it's not about the individual
IQ of the team members it's about the
collective eq of the team members that
will result in a in a great team and a
winning results
so think of this as what would be the
impact of including women and being open
to recruiting hiring and working with
women in a more open and collegial way
in the workforce and adopting a growth
mindset in terms of colleagues on the at
work
so being gender smart you can build an
awesome team through gender diversity
and I always call it the three P's and
this is from the body of research that I
have profitability performance and
productivity now it seems that somewhere
along the line the body remembers Star
Trek Voyager yes how many Lucy's few
women here right and can we then we also
have kathryn janeway the captain who was
a loyal effective team leader and
commander who you know was great on Star
Trek so it seems like we we had this
notion in the past at some point along
the time and we forgot it so what I'm
saying is let's adopt this let's reboot
let's adopt this attitude and this
inclusionary spirit that we had at one
point but which somehow we got away from
so right now there's a tremendous effort
from the White House to the government
to school's academic institutions
foundations profit nonprofit everybody
seems to be focusing on the area of STEM
education and stem productivity because
technology is galloping forward we
cannot have we cannot have a 1950s
corporate culture with a focus on
exclusion when we're dealing with the
Internet of Things Big Data predictive
analytics and galloping forward at the
speed of light with technology we need a
workforce that is up to speed to support
the achievements that we're making in
digital in our digital society
so I am urging everybody to have a
growth mindset and to be open to the
possibilities of not yet which is the
solution and affixed to our educational
and corporate culture deficits to our
low performance on the Pisa scores of
math science and reading too are
underperforming economy and to our lack
of gender representation in our
companies I am asking us all to create
an environment that is overflowing with
not yet I am asking you all to be on
fire with the winning spirit of not yet
let's not waste talent let's harness our
human resources of our female gender
human resources and let's adopt the
great winning concept of not yet let's
take advantage of the economic
contribution to our national growth that
a stronger percentage of women in the
population and the workforce can make in
the immortal words of tony robbins
change is inevitable but progress is
optional so i'm asking us all to make
progress to adopt a growth mindset in to
change our culture and the reason is
that it's very hard to change it's
really a pain in the neck maybe other
places too
it's very very hard to change but the
pain of discipline and the pain of
changing is a short-term pain whereas
the pain and the consequences of not
changing leads to regret and that pain
is a pain that lasts a long time could
last a lifetime and that's the pain of
discipline and the power of not yet
thank you I think I'm right on time for
the the next speaker
would you do have a question
it's a very it's if I think it's I think
the tech and STEM fields are very very
attractive to women because the tech
fields are typically very diversified
you need a number of different skill
sets you need programming languages
business line business comes in handy
and now analytics comes in handy and so
the more arrows you have in your quiver
or so to speak the more the easier it is
to find another job and to move so yes I
think it's it's very different this very
it's a very very diverse area that has a
lot of promise for women
well that's an interesting question and
I'm not sure that I have the whole
answer to that but I know that having
computers and teaching computer science
in schools is something that's going on
like mayor de Blasio here in New York
has just signed a bill that I think with
over the next ten years mandates
computer science training in class I
think it's a question of some hard
training and hard skill set acquiring
but also I think it's the emphasis
according to Carol Dweck she which he
recommends is an emphasis on learning
and and working hard to achieve goals
not so much just on passing tests
what are some
courage
people
well that's that's also a great question
the last year mid-year the Silicon
Valley companies published their gender
diversity percentages and it was I think
the first time that they ever came out
and said you know what SWAT and there
are a lot of different policies and and
programs and initiatives that are going
on within those companies for example on
the policy side they have both paternity
and maternity leaves that are very very
strong both for men and women for the
women there's a lot of different things
that are going on for example I know at
Microsoft Microsoft absolutely blows me
away in terms of the programs that
they're doing for example they have
mandated videos on unconscious bias so
that everybody takes training on since
being sensitive to unconscious bias in
the work in the workplace it's it's just
one of many many areas that they that
they are a leader in and some other
companies have are doing blind
recruiting so in it in other words the
relief they don't show the names on
applications so you have to you know
sort of get there you know that they
hire people in the initial couple of
rounds it's it's it's gender blind
yes do you think that the strategies for
finding great female candidates are any
different from the strategies for
funding rate male candidates I believe
in in hiring great candidates and women
I interviewed all were very very much
sounded in one unanimous voice that they
wanted to be hired not because they were
women but because they were good at what
they do so I really think that you can
aim for diversity but it's best thing to
do is to hire talent
working with universities or just you
know trying to spread the spread throw
out a net and get good candidates I
wouldn't be able to tell you how how
that's done that would be an HR function
my experience there's very dearly total
lack of correlation personality
characteristics at least
characteristics the lead to a successful
satisfying career seems to me that
rather than trying to fool people many
people as possible
two poles protocol Panama to do a better
job of communicating
to the
middle school high school level what
those deals really are about yeah and
secondly who in kind of a better job of
attracting
have a satisfying successful for the
long haul yeah enter the pipeline right
I agree with you I think that in general
the tech and STEM fields need an image
makeover especially for the female
population because I think that too
often women think of these tech fields
as being nerdy neurotic whacka whacka
Dill's these are very these are very
very creative and problem solving and
fun-filled there's a lot of excitement
to be to be had when you solve a
business problem through data and data
analytics it's fun so people don't
realize that I agree with you I see mine
otherwise we'll wrap it up and thanks
for making ok great